Eh ben oui !
Eh ben salut !
Eh ben d'accord !
Eh ben bonjour !
Salut ! Il est 11h, on est dimanche.
Et donc c'est le jour de l'explication de la semaine !
Puisque tous les dimanches à 11h, je t'apprends un tour
qui va te permettre de bluffer tes amis, et ta famille aussi si jamais tu as un repas de famille dans 1h
et au lieu de te lever tu regardes mes vidéos sur YouTube !
Haha !
Et aujourd'hui, je vais te donner 4 clefs
qui vont te permettre d'avoir 80% de réussite
lorsque tu joues au Chifoumi.
Le jeu du Chifoumi, c'est le jeu où on a la main dans le dos,
et qu'on fait:
"pierre"
"feuille"
"ciseaux"
Et hop, on fait le truc
Donc ça, c'est "feuille"
ça c'est "pierre"
ça aurait été tellement drôle qu'un pote qui s'appelle Pierre qui passe derrière !
et ça évidemment ce sont des...
Non, des doigts !
Oh ! La bonne vanne !
Évidemment, ça ce sont des "ciseaux" !
Donc tu connais le jeu, quand t'es avec quelqu'un chacun fait son signe.
Et on compare, et on voit quel signe gagne.
Donc, la feuille gagne la pierre,
la pierre gagne les ciseaux,
et les ciseaux coupent la feuille.
C'est donc un cercle complètement équilibré
puisque chaque figure gagne sur une autre, et en bat une autre
Et moi, j'ai 4 astuces pour avoir 80% de réussite !
Et je te les donne !
Bien sûr que je te les donne !
C'est le but du dimanche !
Des fois j'ai des yeux de fous quand j'avance...!
Ma première astuce se base sur un principe psychologique assez simple.
En France, souvent, on joue à "feuille, pierre, ciseaux ou puits".
On a rajouté le puits, ce qui n'a pas de sens,
puisque lui il se fait battre par 1 seule figure : la feuille,
et il en bat 2 : les ciseaux et la pierre.
Mais dans le vrai Chifoumi, il n'y a pas ça.
Et donc vous allez le rappeler à votre adversaire.
Vous lui dites simplement :
"Eh ! On fait un Chifoumi, par contre il n'y a pas de puits ! Ok ?!"
Le fait de lui rappeler qu'il n'y a pas de puits,
c'est une espèce de suggestion pour qu'il prenne la pierre.
Parce que comme le puits est une figure très puissante,
puisqu'elle gagne sur deux,
il va chercher dans sa tête, le plus fort, juste après le puits, d'après lui.
Et comme ce jeu, se base sur des images très simples
il va choisir la pierre qui est un signe de force.
Alors qu'en fait, statistiquement ils ont les mêmes chances de gagner.
Donc comme il y a de fortes chances qu'ayant dit cette phrase juste avant, il prenne la pierre au premier coup,
au premier coup vous allez prendre la feuille !
Essayez-le vraiment de cette manière, et vous allez quasiment systématiquement gagner au premier coup.
Au fait, je vous dit rapidement, j'essaie d'arrêter de vous tutoyer dans les vidéos
parce que ça n'a pas de sens, je mélange le "vous" et le "tu"
et je me rends compte que je viens de mélanger les deux.
Bon je continue quand même mais excusez-moi, si je fais des trucs bizarres dès fois quand je parle.
Je vous disais, j'ai jamais partagé cette première astuce avec quelqu'un
et elle me fait gagner quasiment systématiquement le premier coup
donc faites-le, vous allez voir c'est assez fun et ça va vous faire rire !
La deuxième astuce est simplement de l'ordre statistique, mais elle est vérifiée.
Un joueur fait rarement 3 fois la même figure d'affilé.
Ça c'est quelque chose que vous pouvez prendre en compte.
Si quelqu'un fait deux fois ciseaux, il va pas faire trois fois ciseaux ou alors c'est extrêmement rare
C'est quelque chose que vous devez garder à l'esprit, en permanence pour "switcher".
Et les deux autres astuces me viennent d'une université chinoise.
L'université de Zhejiang
Je ne sais pas si je prononce bien.
Je n'ai pas l'accent chinois...
Elle s'appelle Zhéjiang.
Et il y a deux ans, ils ont réuni 360 étudiants,
et durant 2 heures, ils ont fait des matchs de Chifoumi
et ils ont observé ce qu'il se passait en terme de résultat
pour l'associer à un processus psychologique vérifié.
Il en est ressorti 2 conclusions, qui permettent de gagner 2 fois sur 3.
2 fois sur 3 c'est 66% de chance !
C'est énorme !
Déjà ça se base sur le fait qu'on dise toujours "pierre, feuille, ciseaux", qu'on joue dans cet ordre là.
D'ailleurs "Chifoumi" signifie "pierre, feuille, ciseaux".
Donc je parle chinois en fait !
Et tout est basé sur ce qu'il vient de se passer du point de vue de votre adversaire
pour essayer d'anticiper son prochain coup.
Il y a deux choses à savoir.
Si vous faites un coup et que l'adversaire gagne,
le joueur d'en face vient juste de gagner, vous venez de faire "pierre" par exemple, il a fait "feuille", donc il a gagné.
Au coup d'après, vous devez jouer ce qui vous aurez fait gagner ce coup là.
Quand un joueur gagne, il a tendance à refaire le même symbole, au coup d'après.
Donc s'il gagne avec "pierre", au coup d'après il y aura 2 chances sur 3
pour qu'il joue "pierre" de nouveau.
Donc si vous venez de perdre contre "pierre" avec les "ciseaux"
Au coup d'après vous faites la "feuille", et il y a 2 chances sur 3 pour qu'il fasse la "pierre" et que vous gagnez ce coup là !
Mais si votre adversaire perd, alors il a tendance à changer de signe pour le signe après.
dans la routine "pierre-feuille-ciseaux".
Donc, si il joue "pierre", et qu'il perd contre vous,
au coup d'après, il va faire "feuille".
Du moins, il y a 2 chances sur 3 pour qu'il fasse "feuille" au coup d'après.
Pour vous en rappeler plus facilement, de votre point de vue à vous,
si vous perdez, vous jouez la figure d'avant dans la routine "pierre-feuille-ciseaux".
Si vous perdez avec "feuille", vous faites "pierre" au coup d'après.
Et si vous gagnez, au coup d'après vous faites le symbole suivant.
Donc, si vous gagnez avec "ciseaux", vous faites "pierre" au coup d'après.
C'est très simple, ça vous donne 2 chances sur 3 de gagner à chaque fois.
C'est à dire que si vous jouez un match en 10 coups avec quelqu'un, vous appliquez ma première astuce pour le premier coup
ensuite vous appliquez ces deux astuces là en cas de gain ou de perte, systématiquement.
Gardez tout de même en tête,  ma deuxième astuce qui était "un joueur ne joue jamais 3 fois le même symbole d'affilé".
Et vous êtes sûr qu'en 10 coups, vous gagnerez votre partie de Chifoumi.
Et là tu peux te faire plaisir au niveau des paris !
Vous voyez, par exemple : "Qui va ranger l'appartement?"
-Ecoute, je te propose une partie de Chifoumi en 10 coups pour déterminer ça.
C'est pas très compliqué.
Gardez bien ces quatre astuces en tête.
Amusez-vous. Bluffez tout le monde !
Gagnez !
Likez cette page !
Mettez un pouce en l'air ! Commentez ! Abonnez-vous !
Suivez le MentalVlog, à demain à 17h !
Ciao !